great week for you now we turn to our
other top story tonight
the dangerous consequences of the
democrats deep fund dismantled the
police agenda
which is now delivering a brutal reality
check to even its biggest supporters for
example
atlanta councilman mayoral candidate
antonio brown
he voted to defund the police and had
his beautiful white mercedes
stolen in broad daylight by a bunch of
kids this week
now telling local media that they were
more than 11 or 12 years old police
eventually found the vehicle a few hours
later
and out in chicago there is a new foot
chase policy
to further paralyze police it actually
bans
officers from giving chase for minor
traffic violations
and they must not separate from partners
oh how's that going to make communities
safer how does it does it
isn't that going to make the job of
officers
a lot harder to stop crime and look at
your screen here in new york shocking
video shows
a tuesday shootout on the upper west
side new york city in broad daylight
two men exchanging gunfire and fired
multiple times
but that's the response to acts of
violence like this
from far left activists to continue
attacking police
now look at this video from kansas city
it shows a blm
demonstrator talking about carrying out
revenge killings against police officers
for the death of george floyd take a
look you decide
because baby we don't get
about the police chicago
let them kill one of ours that's what
we're doing
we killed one of theirs in chicago baby
we're going to knock on your door
um we're going to blow your head
we're going to blow their mother effing
head off where's the outlet rage from
the left
where's the calls for accountability for
this evil reckless rhetoric new poll
fox news showing that a whopping 7 in 10
voters think crime is on the rise 77
percent of urban voters saying crime is
up
but of course just like clockwork rather
than take any responsibility
for this undeniable truth and disaster
of an anti-police agenda
democrats well they're just doing what
they always do if the dog
bites if the bee stings if you're
feeling sad
just blame donald trump or is james
carville now urging his fellow democrats
to blame donald trump for surging crime
james uh who are the ones writing in
every sitter last summer
and by the way who were the people
denying that riots were riots
who were the ones calling to defund and
dismantle the police
it wasn't donald trump who was the one
that said police become the enemy
and who was the one that promoted a bail
fund for minnesota writers
oh joe and and kamala here with reaction
host of the dan bongino show weekdays
from fox nation
noon to three fox news contributor dan
bongino sir
welcome back thank you i don't even know
what to talk to you
okay defund dismantle
uh then we've got you know no bail laws
now we have even new considerations and
then when all else fails just blame
trump
this you see now the stats
what's happening more people are getting
shot more people are dying
yeah i saw portland was up 800 percent
la 144
shootings homicides you know sean in in
the history of liberal stupid ideas and
believe me there are a lot of them open
borders confiscatory taxes
government-run healthcare i mean the
list of dumb ideas is long and strong
but i'll tell you defunding the police
is the
single dumbest idea liberals have ever
produced
a matter of fact there's not even if
we're an olympics of stupidity
there's a goal but there's no silver and
bronze that they're on the podium stand
themselves the people who celebrated
this absurdity of defunding the police
now the problem with this this isn't
funny
we enjoy it but people are dying people
are being killed
and i'll tell you who i blame i don't
only blame liberals for
celebrating this stupid idea but the
media for not calling them out early
the media propagated this myth that the
police officers were the enemy
and the criminals were really the good
guys so what did people do in liberal
cities attacked the police
coddled the criminals and shocker sean
people are dying in liberal cities all
over america because of this
tragic stupidity hey sean hannity here
hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else